The line between imagination and reality has long
been the realm of cinematic
and literary exploration.
But now, thanks to research
published in 2023,
Scientists are gaining new insights
into one of the most mysterious
transitions in human consciousness -
the shift from reality based perception
to internal, imaginative brain states.
Imagination really allows you to come up with what things
would be like in alternative realities,
which is something that's really powerful.
It can help you plan things.
You can imagine, okay,
if I'm going to have this dinner,
what's what is it going to taste like?
If that's something I like?
Okay, well, then let me go
and make that for dinner, for example.
So it allows you to really like, plan
your future.
it's just interesting to know
how your brain distinguishes internally
generated content from stuff
that is out there in the world.
But scientists have long struggled
to understand the puzzling neuroscience
behind our ability to distinguish
between perception and imagination,
since both use
many of the same parts of the brain.
in 1910, psychologist Mary
Perky was trying to develop
a scientific definition of imagination.
So she devised an experiment
that produced a surprising result.
Test subjects were asked to stare at
a blank wall and imagine a certain fruit.
Meanwhile, behind the scenes, Perky
projected a very faint image of the fruit
on the wall.
When asked if they saw anything real,
the participants were sure they hadn't,
although they commented on how vivid
the image they were imagining
seemed.
Perky concluded that
when our perception of something matches what we're imagining,
we will assume we've imagined it.
This would eventually come to be known
as the Perky effect.
Since then there's been a handful
of studies that tried to replicate it,
but the results were very mixed,
Nonetheless, decades kind of with
the advancement of neuroimaging, we've shown time and time again
that when we imagine something
many of the same brain
processes becoming involved as when
we would actually see that same thing.
So Dykstra and her team designed
an updated version of Perky's experiment.
The setup was similar.
But to better control for the variability
in imagined objects,
the researchers asked participants
to imagine something more specific:
diagonal lines.
Participants stared at a static screen
and were asked to imagine
the lines, just as in Perky's experiment,
faint images would appear and disappear.
What we found was actually kind of surprising
because we did not find a Perky effect.
instead,
in results published in 2023, a more
nuanced picture emerged.
When the researchers
asked participants if the lines they saw
were real or imagined,
the responses varied.
When they were shown faint
images of the lines.
Participants
were more likely to report seeing them,
and when they weren't shown the lines.
some still reported seeing them
suggesting vivid imaginations at work.
So taken together,
what we can kind of conclude from this is
that when imagination gets really vivid,
it can be mistaken for reality.
so the way that we are thinking about this
now is that
this is all to do with sensory strength.
Unlike perky, Dykstra went beyond
first person reporting.
She and her collaborators analyzed
neuroimaging data from the participants
in their study.
What they saw suggests that the visual
and prefrontal cortices may be directly
involved in the process of distinguishing
imagination from reality.
So I intuitively always thought
it was going to be more like a switch.
But the research seems to suggest that
it might be more like a gradual meter.
But then the way you're interpreting
this is more binary.
So like once it crosses some threshold,
you're like, now it's real,
and before that it's not real.
And that point is what we call
the reality threshold.
And they're basically saying
that the way that we distinguish
what is seen versus what is imagined,
that strength of this representation.
has to exceed the threshold
for us to consider it real
or out there in the world.
And that's something
that we're really keen
to investigate further,
whether we can get measures of this
in individual people
and then see if that relates to things
like hallucination proneness
or schizophrenia or sometimes
in Parkinson's, people experience
these really vivid hallucinations
that are actually imaginations,
but they feel real to these people.
So one hypothesis would be that
something is wrong in their reality
threshold the more I learn,
the more questions I have
and the more I want to keep going.
Humans
are made of nearly 70 trillion cells,
but only half of them are truly ours.
The other half are foreign microbes,
collectively called the human microbiome.
Covering us inside and out,
this intricate ecosystem helps
us digest food and fight off disease.
Even though the microbiome
is an essential part of who we are,
it's still largely a mystery to science.
Researchers have been trying
to better understand
how we acquire these foreign microbes
and if they're exchanged freely
between people
like other germs.
So we say microbiome, but this means
many different species,
hundreds to thousands.
So it's not just studying one pathogen,
we have to study so many microorganisms,
all of them are different
These organisms vary in terms
of their genomes, their functions,
what they're doing, why they're there,
how they interface with the human body.
And that presents
a lot of different challenges
how to grow these organisms, how to study
their different and various functions.
There's another reason
our microbiome is tricky to study.
Its inhabitants are constantly changing.
At birth we have an imprinting
of the bacteria from the
and from the environment.
And then we continuously update,
improve, change,
modify
our microbiome during all our lifetime.
This year, a team of biologists
at the University of Trento
in Italy developed new ways to trace
genetic strains of microbes
as they pass between individuals.
So we try to collect as many samples
as possible to get a global understanding
of microbiome transmission
in the different lifestyles in the planet.
We collected more than 9000 samples
for the gut and the microbiome,
so stool and saliva samples
in more than 30 different countries.
We just sequence
all the DNA that's there in the sample.
The challenge here is to make sense
of the sequencing data, considering that
we are not looking at one individual but
a community of individuals all together.
Comparing the individual's data
across familial and social networks,
the researchers wanted to know
if microorganisms in the microbiome
could spread from person to person,
like a cold or a stomach bug.
And what they found suggests that microbes
hop much more extensively
than we thought between people
in close physical proximity,
like roommates, spouses and children.
The power of our study was really
that what we saw was consistent
across all these populations
and different lifestyles.
There is really a massive transmission
of human
microbiome members
directly through social interactions.
So our social activity impacts
our microbiome,
which in turn impact our biology.
So, the way and the people we interact
with is impacting
our biology, our medical history.
I think it warrants additional study
into the dynamics and the true sources
and the full range of sources
where these organisms come from.
But this is a huge step in
understanding the transmission landscape.
As humans evolved,
our microbiomes may have evolved
with us
to protect our health and immunity.
But with the continued use of antibiotics
and antiseptics in the modern world,
we may be throwing off our body's natural
microbial balance and leaving ourselves.
more susceptible to the health risks.
The more we study it, the more we realize
that the microbiome underlies
a lot of different immune
related disorders in the body.
So many of these are chronic conditions,
things like cancers, autoimmunity
inflammatory bowel disease
and diabetes, multiple sclerosis
and many other disorders.
And so we typically didn't understand
the root causes of those diseases.
But as we explore them more,
they're not only genetic
and environmental,
but they have a lot to do with
these organisms that live within our body.
We cannot fully infer causality,
so we don't know
if the disease occurs first of them
or the microbiome alterations.
And so it's very important
to us to understand
how we acquired this bacteria and how
we transmit them to other individuals.
This is a human embryo.
This is a mouse embryo.
They both start growing
and building a body in much the same way.
But then something strange happens,
the human embryo's development slows down
and the mouse's accelerates.
As far as we can tell, every step
takes about 2 to 3 times
longer in the human embryo than a
in the mouse embryo.
How and when different embryonic tissues
develop can dramatically alter
an organism's form.
But a mystery persists.
What controls this difference in timing?
New evidence suggests
the mysterious conductor driving
development is an organelle scientists
may have written off as a one trick pony.
So when people think about mitochondria,
traditionally,
they think about the powerhouse
of the cell,
which is producing ATP to provide energy
for studying our functions.
But they're also involved in signaling,
there is a lot more going on in
mitochondria than just energy production.
To figure out the causal relationship
between activity
in the mitochondria
and the timing of embryonic development.
researchers at Harvard Medical School,
manipulated different regions
within the mitochondria of human and mouse
stem cells.
and in early 2023,
they published their results.
So we observe that mouse cells produce
protein faster
through the process
of mRNA translation than human cells.
And we found that if we experimentally
increased the activity of mitochondria,
we could also force the cells to produce
protein faster and develop faster.
This finding was then echoed by
a team of researchers working in Belgium
in a paper they published in Science
just weeks later, which pointed towards
the mitochondria's role in developmental
timing in the nervous system.
Mitochondria is important in many aspects.
Just not only the ATP protein
and the metabolite production.
And the what we found is a mitochondria
is a working as a pacemaker of the
speed of the development
in cells. I think very important
next question is how
mitochondrial activity regulate
gene regulatory network
because gene regulatory network
is also important to regulate the timing
of that development.
This research could have
major implications for cell therapy,
which is when damaged cells are replaced
by healthy cells, and cancer research.
If we can find a way
by setting developmental speed
to accelerate the production
of cells for therapies, then that would be
really important in accelerating
the cell therapy revolution.
Tempo is important
to make up different outcome.
That's why
mitochondria is that important
pacemaker and the make
a diversity of our animal kingdom.
So they have out this kind of as a function as a driving force of the evolution.